alright so welcome to part two again I'm
talking about multi-dimensional and
nonlinear mechanism design today the the
main goal is to focus on solving the
single agent problems however I did not
finish one of my agenda items from
yesterday so I'm going to start by
finishing that agenda item to remind you
we were looking at multi to single agent
reductions and we had given a reduction
under an assumption of revenue linearity
which was basically saying if you want
to think about a mult of an auction
given an allocation rule which is a
complicated function governing the
probability that types are served it's a
bunch of how strong they are that
auction will always look like a convex
combination of very simple mechanisms
that are the Optima isms if you're just
going to consider an ex ante constraint
probability of service so in other words
these complicated mechanisms look like
convex combinations of very simple
mechanisms and so their revenue is going
to be the convex combination of the
revenue the simple mechanisms and that's
exactly what rubber linearity is saying
it's a revenue is a convex combination
of revenue of things to come from convex
combinations okay so the focus of today
is going to be looking at how to solve
meka design problems reducing the
multiplayer problem to single player
problems when you don't have this nice
reven linearity property okay meaning if
I give you some allocation rule and you
want to find the optimal exit for that
it will not look like the a convex
combination of simple mechanisms that
come from these ex-ante pricing problems
ok so this single agent problem as I
said it will have a constraint on the
entire allocation rule to build
multiplayer mechanisms from
single-player mechanisms we're going to
look at a method of stochastic way to
optimization and see how that allows us
to resolve the multiplayer problem
there'll be no assumptions and so it'll
handle general mom multi racial
preferences and also general risk
aversion or budgets yeah is what's
fundamental revenue linearity were more
than or durability property do you think
so rubbing linearity implies or
durability rubbing linearity implies or
durability okay and the converse is not
true but sort of in a pathological way
so I wouldn't worry about it so much so
I don't think that distinction is very
interesting I would think of them is the
same I want to clear up some questions
that I got last time from people after
the talk to get us all on the same page
okay so one question is how do you prove
rubbery linearity I have a setting I'm
wondering to thread your linear how do I
prove it and I'll give you two answers 1
answer if it is if there's a payment
identity meaning i can tell you the
revenue of any mechanism just by looking
at its allocation rule okay then its
revenue linear has to be because one way
to construct the mechas met allocation
will take commas combinations of other
mechanisms and so the only way to do it
is the way that has that same revenue
one good auction case of identity is
easy in these other cases I mean fine
jess is a I have be in my taste it might
take some work to establish and thinking
it multi attribute multi good thing is
if you an identity your end up lots of
work to prove it I was that's correct
and in the single player question the so
that's correct and so it which is why
I'm gonna give you another way to prove
revenue linearity and and I before doing
that though I want to point out single
dimensional linear preferences have a
pain identity we know that
multi-dimensional preferences do not
have a payment identity and even the
cases that were revenue linear don't
have a payment identity so I just want
to draw you a picture to remind you we
saw let's see this mechanism which sold
will probably won't happen so it has an
allocation rule that looks like this
right this was was it
you know what this was a square root of
one-half good thanks so this was the
allocation rules why of Q and this was
the allocation in type space where this
is t 1 and this is t 2 and you get item
one here item to hear okay we saw
another mechanism that had allocation
rule the same allocation rule and that
was for instance just sell item 1 right
and that has the exact same allocation
rule right if you do this you get a
revenue square root one half which is
bigger than if you do this which is a
red move one half same allocation rule
different revenues no payment identity
for when I write things in terms of
these allocation rules
okay the other approach is the existence
of virtual values okay so what are
virtual values i'm going to get to this
much more in the later part of the talk
today this might be a little bit basic
but it's the reason that you don't have
a payment identity for multi-dimensional
types basically because you're squashing
the squashing the dimensions down to one
dimension for your allocation rule so
you're certainly yes yes and you could
define a payment identity in terms of
these pictures and then they do have one
if I give you a picture here and I tell
you down the Magnum is the same picture
here in terms of who wins it has the
same revenue okay so in terms of these
pictures they have the same revenue but
for composing multiplayer mechanism from
single player Meccans this is what I
care about okay this stuff doesn't
really matter so much and I need to pay
my identity here in order to get have
this done you got this this build up
okay so why do virtual values tell me
that its revenue linear so remember and
we'll get into some more detail for
those of you who know what virtual
values are virtual values let me write
revenue as the expectation of a virtual
value times the probability of service
which is fundamentally a linear this
layer right so having written things as
a virtual value I've just written down
that the revenue must be linear okay and
so we'll talk about more that later when
we develop virtual values for this
setting whereby we'll be able to confirm
that this is revenue linear okay good so
I another great question about the Apple
Mexican for the uniform 0 1 squared
which I talked about which was basically
you always sell the guy whose favorite
item and attention looks like uniform
prices like this so basically this or
comments combinations of these are what
often my cousin look like okay another
great question which was well this just
looks like you're collapsing the
multi-dimensional type space into a
single dimension which is the agents
value for his favorite object the answer
is yes and in fact for the uniform 0 1
squared case this is optimal its optimal
to collapse types to a single
dimensional type it is not generally
optimal to do that and so the task is to
understand when it's generally optimal
to collapse the type space to a single
dimensional type okay and that's again
what's going to happen later today okay
yes that's what we did or what will have
to have happened and will prove it today
okay the before I go into this more
complex production to get multiplayer
mechelen from single-player Meccans I
want to talk it's going to be
complicated and you're going to wish we
didn't live in that world okay and so I
want to tell you that you can
approximately not live in that world in
other words if you're happy to give up a
little bit of the optimal revenue you
can stay in the rut you can basically
pretend it was revenue linear and use
the marginal revenue mechanism we talked
about the other day and things will be
okay okay so I want to tell you how to
get approximate ex ante reduction
without revenue linearity and so here's
the idea of marginal revenue based
mechanism is one that always looks to
every agent like it's a convex
combination of the ex ante Apple
mechanisms okay so you're not doing
funny or things that just comebacks
combining these mechanisms so even
though it would be optimal do something
better for some allocation well I'm just
going to do the simple thing and take
the convex combination of them okay and
the challenge in understanding how well
our marginal revenue mechanism does
compared to the optimal mechanism is
that the optimal one is not marginal
revenue based it does some complicated
thing that's not doing marginal revenue
so here's the idea let's relax the ex
post feasibility constraints so think of
this as we had one item to sell let's
relax the facts we have 1i in a cell to
cell one item in expectation okay so
relaxed expose feasibility to hold X
auntie or an expectation okay if you do
that then the constraint that one agent
poses on the other agents is well if he
gets it with some anxiety probability
that means you can't give the other
agent with that ex ante probability so
that poses an ex ante can strengthen the
other agent not an interim constraint
okay
so the optimal solution to the X on T
relaxation is actually marginal revenue
based it's going to be only using ex
ante pricings in its solution
every single dimensional linear agent
mechanism is marginal revenue based and
that falls because of the payment
identity because every maxim revenue
comes from a mite any they're all
marginal revenue base okay what does
that mean that means any approximation
result that you prove for single
dimensional agents against the X on T
upper bound the ex-ante relaxation will
automatically extend to general agents
using the marker revenue based approach
okay and it's just if you use the
building block of single dimensional
agents and you prove a theorem where the
upper bound also uses the building
blocks of single dimensional agents and
everything just comes for free
okay so let's suppose you wanted
approximations to get arbitrarily close
to optimal if you had a large number of
items like k items then the ex-ante
feasibility constraint is very very
close to the ex post fees billikin
strained and your approximation factor
goes to 1 okay that's one answer to your
question I don't have a better
understanding of of what this with this
benchmark the ex ante relaxation means
whether it has an economic
interpretation but it's sort of it's
it's one of those things that would be
sort of vacuous in large markets like it
would always be true in large markets
because large numbers like the agent
preference don't matter because they are
coming from a continuum now and so we
just be true
okay so for instance the posted price
your anonymous pricing approximation
results that are proven for single men
shell settings automatically extend
these settings and these are two of the
things I named out for you in the first
slide of the first talk saying these are
the examples of where get approximation
okay so I now want to talk about what i
call the interim reduction or the
reduction without revenue linearity ok
and this reduction comes from a joint
paper with saddle I who foo aneema and
Asura and Sade as I said before is
around who foo is going to be here for
the semester also and nima is also here
for the semester so if you think this
stuff is important and you want to learn
more about it you can talk to any of
these guys you're going to be here all
all term ok it's very closely related to
some recent work by chi des caucus and
Weinberg and it builds upon a lot of the
classical auction theory especially the
auction theory for nonlinear preferences
like budgets or risk aversion okay and
remember my working example for the this
interim production was the case of a
public budget there was a reason for
that because that's what the these
original works were talking about okay
and one of the interesting things about
what we did in this paper he said that
the stuff that they're these tools are
using to solve but nonlinear case can
also solve multi-dimensional cases using
this framework of the multiplayer single
player reduction
okay so what's my approach
so I'm going to call a profile of
interim allocation constraints y hat
where this is really just an functions
one for each player which is the
allocation constraint for that player
I'm going to call that profile interim
feasible if there exists some ex post
allocation rule which I'm going to note
y hat EP which is actually a function
from quantile profiles so all the types
of the players to a feasible outcome and
so X is just some subset of all outcomes
it's feasible this could be anything you
want okay I want you to think for this
talk of single item settings so this is
anything that sums to at most one they
just think single item settings me think
beezubul here
nope and in fact interim feasibility
will not consider in something
compatible ate all the next slide will
make it really clear what I'm talking
about okay great question okay so what
do I mean by this this ex post
allocation rule induces these interim
allocation profiles it means i can get
each profile by taking the expectation
of the allocation rule for a quantile
profile drawn from the distribution of
quantiles which is always iid uniform 01
okay so I just calculate this I get
allocation rules this is what it means
to be interim feasible okay here's the
theorem the optimal revenue is given by
the following program I maximize overall
allocation constraints profiles of
allocation constraints the one for each
player the optimal revenue I can get
from that allocation constraint remember
Rev is a revenue operator takes this
constraint gives you the best revenue of
every map single-player mechanism with
that constraint subject to this profile
y hat being interim pisal meaning there
exists some other mechanism that doesn't
have to be incentive compatible what is
feasible
okay so I'd like to understand what
optimizing this program means well first
I want to get proof that its optimal but
this theorem is correct okay so maybe a
intuition for the proof okay and I want
to understand what this whole approach
is going to mean assumptions before you
spend Khrushchev I mean what we recently
saying in these terms its okay its throw
away capacity and so it's some kind of
monotonicity for you suppose the things
are running around this is something
about objective function and the
sensitives for auctions I mean the
difference is I mean what's what's what
class of economic environments is a
certain form I'm in the settings that
were examples of which were given last
time so I've got independent private
values okay so independence is going to
be important here and I'm that's
basically it
so think independent private value
auction settings don't think necessarily
quasi-linear don't think single ven
channel could be general okay so I'm
going to tell you give you us a the
approach for this theorem from which any
of you could just complete the dots and
finish the theorem I'm going to tell you
how to understand this constraint which
is kind of a strange constraint because
it has a for all in it for all that
exists the mechanism quantified there
I'm going to tell you how you can
restrict attention to a small class of
ex post mechanisms which is all you have
to look at and they're not kind of
simple and so that's the sort of a nice
characterization of what these things
might look like and then I'm going to
talk very briefly about optimization
subject interim feasibility okay so why
is this program correct so first off
this program obviously upper bounds
revenue why well any optimism has to
produce allocation rules or interim
feasible and also for those allocation
rules it's doing the it's doing this
already like these are just the
mechanism it's producing right so the
awful mechanism is a valid solution to
this program okay good so I want to show
the opposite that the the aqua mechanism
that is achieved by this program and
notice there's a disconnection between
mechanisms that do this and mechanisms
that do this right because this is what
I wanted to solve in a penalty for each
player and this is sort of any ex post
feasible thing they had no incentive
constraints at all and so here's the
theorem for any ex post feasible but not
necessarily in sent a compatible
allocation rule so this Y hat XP and any
profile of incentive compatible but not
necessarily ex post feasible mechanisms
why
if the ex post mechanism induces a
profile of constraints y hat and each
why I is feasible for the why I had okay
then you can come up with a combined
mechanism which has the feasibility of
the ex post mechanism and the incentive
properties of the interim mechanisms
okay and the main difficulty here is why
might not be equal to Y hat why I might
not be equal to Y I hat that's the main
difficulty and if you recall how I
define the interim pricing problem
before I said you need to come up with
some Sigma 2 which you can map quantiles
to put into y hat to get why okay and by
that definition of the pricing problem
it's exactly oh you have some Oracle for
y hat how do i turn an Oracle for y hat
into a mechanism actually allocates to
my agent with allocation rule I and
that's what a solution the single aging
problem was doing by that definition
okay so basically by that definition it
follows
which is saying that the definition of
interim pricings are gay before was the
right definition of interim pricings
okay so I want to turn to my next
objective again here was my outline I
want to understand intro feasibility I
want to characterize expose diesel
mechanisms and optimize subject interim
usability so I want to turn to my next
objective which is understanding interim
feasible allocation profile so I want
you to think you have a single item for
sale okay so ex post you better not
allocate more than one item and I want
you to think about these two profile
interim allocation rules one always
allocates the play would probably one
half to the top one half measure of
quantiles allocates with certainty and
the bottom one half measure of quantiles
it doesn't allocate it all ok so these
both have X aunty allocation probability
one-half so my question for you is which
of these three profiles of interim
allocations for a two player one item
setting our interim beezubul for which
of these do there exists an ex post
mechanism that induces these allocation
rules a and B good so a it's just a
lottery right I flip a client give it to
one give it a to that exactly has these
allocation rules for both players good B
is just a dictator Mecca Zamora right
you know I offer player one a price of
that he buys to probably one half if you
said no give to player to put it one
buys it probably half so player 2 gets
it with probably one half which is this
allocation rule see I'll call a double
dictator because i'm giving both the
people the right to buy the thing if
they're in the high half quantiles but
this can't be feasible because what if
they both say yes i only have one item
I'm in trouble ok and here's the main
idea for see what is the probability
that one of the guys is high let's 1
minus the probably that neither are high
neither or high we've probably one half
squared which is a quarter so one is
high with probably three-quarters what
is the expected probability that i need
to allocate to a high type if both
players have this allocation rule ok but
what's the probability that allocates
you a high type with player one it's one
half right well it's the same guy linear
expectation says is one so the expected
number of items I have to allocate the
high types is one but the chance that i
have a high guy showing up is only three
quarters how can I possibly allocate
more items than the guys show more
frequently the guy show up so that's a
violation of interim feasibility
okay so I now want to look at symmetric
cases so the cases where the players are
IID from some distribution they could
have complicated budgets or risk
aversion we just want to look at
symmetric cases and understand interim
feasibility in symmetric cases okay so
let's how is our example though the one
we've been talking about last time which
is two agents I ID from the distribution
and common budget out okay and here's a
fact I want to use if I'm trying to
optimize some symmetric convex program
which the program I'm trying to optimize
was then there's always a symmetric
optimal solution so I can restrict my
attention only to symmetric solutions
that are ensuring feasible and that's
going to make my life really easy okay
and one of the reasons why I want to
focus on this because if you look in the
literature in the 80s and 90s in auction
in economic auction theory you'll find a
lot of solutions to nonlinear cases that
take strong advantage of the symmetry
assumption and basically using this
property but i'm going to describe right
here okay so here's the lemma
the ex post mechanism by you to think
about there's only one it is the highest
quantile wins mechanism so in other
words I take a profile of quantiles and
I serve the player the one with has the
strongest quantile which is actually the
lowest quant odd because quantiles goes
strong as low week is high ok so the
strongest quantel wins is the optimal ex
post feasible allocation constraint for
my program ok it's obviously interim
feasible its interim feasible because I
defined it with an ex post mechanism and
said there's it induces some allocation
rule good so I'm going to prove this so
what am I saying I'm saying there are no
other symmetric allocation rules that
are interim feasible that are better
than this allocation rule in terms of
revenue and to do that
okay so now I'm sorry defining
poptropica mechanism for our allocation
world right good education rolling and
so now who the strongest upon College
depends on the allocations so you're 26
first canto engine starts particle wins
with respect allocation rule a is off
yeah so i want to i want to remind you
that once I've done this I'm just going
to talk in terms of quantiles from the
distribution to talk about feasibility
so I no longer have types later I'm
going to have to the single player
problem has it actually turn types into
quantiles for me we talked about the
strongest upon tell you first fix this
will fix some whereupon trust at some
point somewhere so quantiles are defined
to be ordered where the lowest one is
strongest and like zero is strongest one
is weakest when I have a mechanism for
types I can now tell you what the quan
teletype is
based on the ordering that that mecca's
Medusa's on types
lost is strongest hobgoblins his nagging
obviously wrong but I was nagging
feeling it circular because we use
probably wanting to define strikes I've
lost some stuff in the definitions
so I'm separating the problem of coming
up with an apple mechanism for these
players into two steps one is come up
with good allocation rules allocation
rules are just monotone allocations from
Quan falda probably a winning in this
step quantiles are just whoever ends up
being from the mechanism of salt 1 once
I had these allocation constraints I
then have to solve that single player
problem that's going to tell me how to
map types of quantiles okay stronger
than wish and
that's some kind of well you should go
first
this presumption of order of the linear
then no finger is there will be another
type of 15 the point is I am trying to
understand what this constraint means
this constraint comes from this
definition which has nothing to do with
types
nothing dude incentives nothing do it
types nothing okay so I'm just try to
understand this definition
okay so for n equals two players with
quantiles drawn uniformly from 01 what
does strongest quantel what does is the
allocation constraint the interim
allocation constraint the strongest
quantile wins induces it's just the
Preble you n is 1 minus Q if your
quantile ki will probably 1 minus Q
because if your Q equals 0 you when
probably one right it's just a line
right that's the fraction people who are
stronger than you from that distribution
okay so in order to prove this lemma I'm
going to show that any symmetric
feasible allocation rules why are also
feasible for y hat okay and therefore
because when I optimize revenue my
program for y hat I'm allowed to choose
something worse something that was
feasible for y hat I might as well just
start with my hat in the first place
I'm going to prove this by contradiction
so suppose Y is infeasible for y hat so
let's remember what feasibility means
remember that these ability was in terms
of the cumulative right we said why was
feasible if for every quantile X aunty
constraint the cumulative probability
allocated below that is less than that
given by the allocation constraint so
this just says suppose it's infeasible
which means there exists some point
where it's bigger for the grimaces
that's correct so I have an allocation
rule being feasible for an allocation
constraint and I have interim
feasibility which is are these are they
feasible for the ex post region exactly
and so and when you think about
optimizing things with a reduction has
two parts right so you have this
optimizing ever single player problems
and not by Z Sigma player problems
there's this optimization has to have
some feasibility property but then when
it sort of makes calls to the single
pipe problem it's got to also satisfy
some feasibility property so this is the
sort of internal feasibility property ok
so what is the probability that player I
has a type that's stronger than Q hat
just keep at this point always uniform
ok so what is the probability that one
of the players one of these two players
is a high type stronger than Q hat well
it's 1 minus the probability that
neither are so it's this right which is
that
okay but how often do we allocate to one
of these guys well the problem the
probability we allocate to a type
stronger things you have by this
allocation rule for considerable player
one was probably allocate to him right
that's just this integral of the
allocation constraint so this
integrating is this allocation can
straight 1 minus Q I get this integral
ok ok I have two players both have to be
allocated with probability at least you
had ok so this is the probability out to
allocate one of these guys if they're a
high type ok and this is the probability
there exists the guy and these are equal
and that better be the case because
remember y hat was feasible ok so y hat
is all good we look at the probability
these guys show up we look at the
probably we allocate their equal but for
the contradiction we assumed that why
was bigger than Y hat at this Q hat
which means when I write this down I'm
going to get a violation of feasibility
I need to serve these guys with more
probability than they show up
okay so any why any of little why with
cumulation will at some point which is
bigger than Y hat meaning it's
infeasible for y just can't be can't be
allocated okay i want to point out again
that if i'm trying to solve this interim
program and then try to solve these
single player problems the interim
program is always solved by the same
solution the Y hats are always highest
quantile wins for a single item auction
which means I'm free to only consider
the single player problem and just solve
it right I don't have to do some
complicated optimization of allocation
profiles and then applies a single
player problem I only have to optimize
the single player problem ok so in other
words that optimization that's a sort of
unique solution to the allocation
constraints which is kind of amazing and
super helpful and which is you know a
large number of papers in the 80s and
90s use this property implicitly not
stating it this way yeah I don't
understand your question but i'm going
to right now map this on to the public
budget case where I think you might
answer your question so maybe could you
ask that question again in a second if
you don't know the answer as long as you
understand me to take the whole power of
doing this change of variables
representation quantel spaces it allows
you to view the optimal mechanism as
we've been as your various single agent
preferences took pushes a preference
dependence part just in the single asian
problem yeah yeah
okay so as I was saying the strongest
want south winds allocations rates
independent of single-agent problem it's
always the best one to use in a
symmetric environment so how do we think
about that let's look at the public
budget example and in the previous talk
I said given an allocation constraint of
Y hat equals 1 minus q what is the
optimal single-agent mechanism and I
drew do I have it here I do have here
great so i took this allocation
constraint i said what was the apple
stick like a mechanism and I said what
does it do well I at the top it's greedy
on some tiny interval and then it
reserve prices the bottom okay so what
is the mapping from types to Quantum's
that I want to use here well the
single-player mechanism is going to say
all these top guys get the exact same
cloth or random quantum as interval
doesn't matter okay these guys get
quantiles sort of equal to their type
relative to the distribution and these
guys aki does no matter either because
they all get price at zero they'll there
they get rejected ok so the single
player problem will resolve how to map
types the quantiles so that the right
thing happens and i get at this curve
as I said before almost all positive
results literature for nominee or
mechanism so budgets risk aversion are
using this fact that the allocation rule
I need at the beginning is just the
strongest quanta wins allocation rule
actually you said almost all can you
give us some examples no I said almost
just to cover my bases so in the nice
case of output chicken strange some
little working symmetric options but
there's such as almost no work and
asymmetric options that all didn't
intersect that with budget constraints
or anything burdens you an interesting
no I said almost because I knew I have
some economists in the audience he might
point out the one paper that didn't do
this that I didn't notice so that's why
I've been almost here okay so I want to
think about the asymmetric case and this
you know the study that the economist
did a budgets and risk aversion actually
prompted border to characterize this
interviews ability constraint more
generally than the symmetric case ok and
the the characterization is actually
literally saying the exact same thing we
said before in our proof we said except
now I'm going to allow you to put
different constraint ex ante constraints
on each type so suppose player one is in
the strongest half the player 2 is in
the strongest quarter and as long as
three is a the player threes in the
strongest third right so if you haven't
a quantile constraint on each player so
weak players on the top you know Q hat
of their quantile okay then this is the
total you have to allocate to those
players in expectation this is the
probability that one of them shows up
one or more of them shows up okay so it
better be but you don't allocate to the
more than one of them shows up so one
direction this is obvious okay and the
great thing that border did was he
proved that it wasn't if and only if
okay then in fact it's a necessary and
sufficient condition ok I want to show
you a very simple proof of this based on
the net the min flomax cut theorem and
network flow which will seem familiar to
a lot of you okay
so this is a network flow graph i'm
going to make so i have a start and a
source and a sink okay and I'm put types
in this graph as follows ok so this
column is profiles of quantiles imagine
I've discretize quantiles so their
profiles of quanta I can discreetly
write this down now so profiles of
quantiles and here I'm going to do two
cases where I have high and low okay and
heisting probably happen locally
probably have so discretize space by
having high tide and low types only okay
so i have two agents in this example and
each can have a low type or a high types
i have 4 profiles of quantiles brooke
wants out profiles possible here I put
every possible type of every agent okay
so player 1 could be low player 2 2
could be low player two could be high
player 2 1 can be high okay and in this
graph I can interpret the flow that's
going to happen from the start to these
these quantel profiles as probability
okay so these are all equally likely so
this is going to be actually a quarter
on each of these okay and then I can
interpret how the flow goes out of a
note here as who wins the object ok so
here when I got low high here the high
type 1 the object and the low type
didn't ok so the flow went this way ok
and then I can interpret the flow here
as what was the interim probability that
type got anything because this is going
to collect all the things that it gets
ok so now I want to so that's how I can
take any mechanism i had and write it
down here you say what is the flow
what's the words of putting it places
sum it up and send it from SOT okay so
any mechanism i can put as a flow in
this graph ok i want to note that this
vertex is connected to two vertices over
here 14 or in general it's going to be
connected to n versys one for the type
of each person in the profile ok so it
gets a l1 and an h2
good so I'm going to add I want to use
the max-flow min-cut theorem climatic
capacities to this graph the capacities
on these edges are just the
probabilities of getting there the
capacities out of these edges are just
the same as the capacity incoming so
universe you can put the total if if
your feasibility was one right you can
put that total one out on any of these
edges right so if you've got sorry if
your if your incoming flow was the
probability of this you can put that
total probability anywhere else so I
just put that flow here that flow also
goes there okay and then the flow i'm
going to put here on this edge is the
flow that i want from the interim
allocation rule that i want to see is if
it's feasible okay so that is this
interim allocation probability of that
thing okay now I'm just asking does
there exist a mechanism that saturates
all these edges okay is the maximum flow
it cut going to be this cut of just
cutting be okay or is there something
else here and so this picture happens to
be I've done this for the dictator
mechanism which I show you before so
player 1 if they're high they get it
otherwise player 2 gets it that was a
feasible mechanism it has this
allocation will player 1 at their high
always gets it okay player too this is
player two's low and high they get will
probably a half each and player 1 if his
load never gets it
here is the double dictator mechanism
okay where what i've done is i've drawn
here of these editor of the capacities
now not flows these are the capacities
yet to put on the edges for the double
dictator mechanism okay so double
dictator serves both high one and high
too with certainty if they show up and
it shows neither of them if a the low
types don't get serve right of the
double dictator and so then you say well
is min pelicula nice cut and in fact no
this has to edges going across it these
are one in one which is two and here i
don't mean three edges of capacity a
quarter each crossing them sorry these
were a half each so it was total one and
these are a quarter reefs like
three-quarters crossing this cut and one
crossing this cut and so I'm inflows
nautical max cut
okay so I in the paper we have on this
we generalize this this border kitchen
to mate roids where the generalization
is that you write the expected rank of
the matronly draw quantiles according to
the probabilities of the quantile
profile I want to point out of interest
to some people here that in 2005 in
particular olmos and Nicole and some
others we're studying d randomization of
auctions and we came up with basically
the exact same flow graph construction
to turn randomized auctions and
deterministic elections in other words
we want to take an auction we're here we
might split the flow right instead you
want to come up with an integral version
of the flow where it only goes to one
place very similar construction in that
paper
okay the next thing on my list slide
shown you the characterization of
interim feasibility
the theorem that you can then say well
what kind of ex post mechanisms you have
to look at to be able to implement all
interim feasible mechanisms and the
answer is stochastic weighted optimizers
and I stochastic way to a partial
following you take any function you want
that randomly max maps types to weights
and then you maximize the weighted sum
of types subject feasibility so this
will give you everything I'm going to
skip my discussion of this I think
Costas will talk about it briefly I'm
going to skip my discussion that's also
because I want to talk about the next
part of my talk the ennis
hey I'm happy to talk about this
construction before in particular
actually i think i want to show you this
picture this is a picture a pictorial
representation of ex post versus interim
feasibility so this is X post usability
if these types show up you can only
serve them you can't serve this guy
didn't show up and then you have this
feasibility constraint okay if this guy
didn't show up you can't serve them so
you can only serve some substance types
do show up and now if you look at what
interim feasibility means it's some
combination of these polytopes it looks
like this in fact I don't want to go
into more detail but I can explain this
picture to you offline if you want to
see more of it okay I was going to talk
about public budgets but i also don't
have time so i want to talk about this
unit demand a single agent problem ok so
again the example you should have in
your mind here is uniform 0 1 squared I
want to prove the thing that I said it's
going to prove the reading this talk
which is that projecting this
multi-dimensional type to a single
dimension is optimal ok this comes from
a paper joint with me mojada who's here
for the semester and this is something
that he's been working on since 2011 and
you know it takes you a while to get the
right answer and it's the right answer
now I'm quite happy with it it's very
closely related to a bunch of recent
interest in computer science in solving
multiplayer problems in Beijing settings
and so here are some papers and it's
also very closely related to some
classic work in particular most reliant
on Armstrong and Roche and shanae
okay so what were my unit demand
preferences again if you have em items
you can have an allocation which is the
simplex so it's a probability you get
each item okay with it some properties
at most one and a payment players have
private types indexing how much they
like each item and the type space I'll
denote by capital T which I'll just
restrict 201 arbitrarily the utility is
the dot product of type in allocation
minus the payment okay I'm going to draw
a case from a distribution with density
function little F of T so think of two
examples which we'll be talking about
today one is the single dimensional case
which we know and love M equals 1 okay
the other is my two-dimensional case
where let's think about the uniform 01
case yeah it does look like added a but
if I have this constraint that can only
serve one of the items it's the same as
unit demand this constraint says you can
only get at most one of the items you're
getting at work more allocating one
thing to you right because the
allocation is the probability simplex on
which I didn't you get that's the point
so the point is one side constraint
allocation to only give you one thing
then someone with additive preferences
over things is the same as I'm with you
need to man preferences or things
because it can only get one thing anyway
so that you know demand curves can trace
not binding that was nikhil's question
for anyone else don't worry about that
I'm going to for all of this talk
constrain myself to item symmetric
distributions like this okay in an item
symmetric distribution the optimal
solution is always symmetric therefore I
can restrict myself to solving it only
on the portion of the type space where
the t1 is bigger the type for the item
one is bigger than the type for every
other item okay so for the unit demand
problem I'm restricting type space this
this part okay and if it was items metro
distribution if I solved the problem
here that I can just put that together
with the symmetric opposite and I get
the general solution this is just as a
notational convenience for me right now
because I just want I just always refer
to one as being the highest type favor
item type no again I'm solving the
single item single agent problem okay
and the stuff I talked about yesterday
for solving the single agent problem for
reb and linear players will solve the
multiplayer problem okay so I want to
consider some motivation for the result
i'm going to give so i'm going to tell
you that under some large family of
distributions we can collapse the
multi-dimensional preference for
different colors of this car to a single
dimensional preference the guy has for
his favorite color car okay so what's
the intuition so if you are thinking
about price discrimination you think huh
I have this car I could paint it red or
blue maybe I can get more money by
discriminating because players have
different values different colors and
the idea of price discrimination is that
price discrimination can improve revenue
if high-value agents are more sensitive
to the different outcomes you're
producing in this pace colors than low
valuations okay so they're willing to
pay a premium to specify exactly what
they want
and the low guys you can give them maybe
a random thing okay so you offer a high
price to choose your color and a low
price for random color this is what you
would want to do if high types were more
sensitive to color than low types so
today I'm going to try to understand the
situations when that's not true there's
no mileage from price discrimination in
other words I want to understand what
this condition which I've written and
formally here hive items are less
sensitive to color what that means and
so I'm going to give you a mathematical
statement for this actually shortly okay
this means the intuition is then price
cremation be unhelpful it's going to be
without loss to project this
multi-dimensional type into a single
dimensional type and having done so your
apple muffin is just a single
dimensional theory okay so you could
either use this the reduction I gave you
yesterday for ex ante pricing or you
could just say well we know what how to
solve a single much problems just do it
okay so you write this thing a bunch of
virtual values and you solve it and
you're done I want to tell you what this
high valuations are less sensitive the
color means okay and so I want to look
at the distribution so remember your t1
is your value for your favorite item so
I'm going to look at the distribution of
your value the ratio of value for your
favorite minh and second highest item
conditioning on your value for your
favorite item ok so if i tell you your
favorite item there's a distribution
that tells you what your second paper
item is drawn from ok what's the
conditional district and talking about
here and then if I think about this
distribution and change your value for
the favorite item that division changes
you change this right so if this is
ordered by first were stochastic
dominance then hi vaya de dejar less
sensitive to color than mobilizations
you never want to price discriminate
so I want to draw a picture
there's a high-value agents are less
sensitive so if you think about density
the in other words let's draw this
picture so say this is probably i'm
going to look at one way to get a handle
on this is let's ask for any type t
what's the probability that your second
value is less than half your first value
the the intuition here is the densities
are getting higher like this way okay so
your mass is getting pushed upward
okay I want to do a warm-up which is
this in fact I'm going to completely
solve the uniforms there one case before
i show how to generalize just two more
dimensions okay and that approach comes
from Armstrong which says let's just
look at the problem condition to raise
coming out of the origin so we
conditioned on the types lying on some
right out of the origin solve the
problem optimally on that type space the
additional type space and then hope that
the conditions are are consistent
okay so listen up the conditional
distribution of your favorite item to be
f max okay and you can figure out what
that is so again I said I want to
condition on the ratio between the two
types and assume that the seller knows
what this ratio is so a seller knows the
types lie on this space now I want to
solve that multi-dimensional aqua micro
design problem okay i want to note that
okay if i tell you that that i might
care about what your distribution of
your of t1 is well that's just the same
as the destruction of F max so
conditioned on this knowledge of theta
you have the same district neff maxed
for your favorite item if following two
problems are the same problem this still
cast of this probabilistic problem where
your values t1 and I can allocate with
probably one or I could allocate it with
probably theta or zero sorry this the
following stochastic on them or this to
item problem where your values t14 item
1 and your values always fade a t14 item
to other words item 2 is the exact same
thing as item one with some probability
okay so these two problems are identical
and we know how to solve this problem if
I have a single item in your values t1
and you can allocate with certainty with
some probability or 0 then we know you
never want to allocate with probability
zero probability theta you always
certain to your zero why you want to
maximize virtual surplus so you want to
serve a types always that have positive
virtual value and some of them never
fam- virtual value which corresponds to
posting the price that inverts the
virtual function which for this
distribution is square root one third
okay this is actually a combination of a
bunch of results in the literature
referred to as no haggling you don't
want to post probabilities okay so these
two problems are isomorphic and then I
want to note that I told the seller
theta and said use this knowledge of the
guys type I'm telling you to find out
the mechanism the guy did it didn't
depend on theta which means the same
mechanism is often without knowledge of
theta so if / theta I want to post this
price that means for every ray out of
the origin I want to post this price so
now I've solved the problem in this half
leave the symmetric solution the top
half which is this and so now we see we
post a price square one third okay that
is the fastest argument of a
multi-dimensional Apple mechanism that I
know of okay there are two challenges to
generalizing this two general types and
one is if you want to generalize the
general types you need to consider paths
that are not raised out of the origin
okay now the problem is there a lot of
passed out of the origin that you could
potentially choose from the cover type
space okay which path you choose so that
selection problem has prevented a lot of
multi-dimensional Mike resign from
proceeding we're going to give a
solution to resolving that problem yeah
so here we're looking at rays I the
origin we're looking at conditioning on
types with this theta which is just a
line out of the origin so you can
imagine cushioning on some other path
right what would be the path you want to
condition on
one way to think about that is no matter
where you condition the distinction
stays the same that's another way to
think about that okay but then you have
to solve Mecca design on not a straight
line okay and if you're solving if I
condition on to some path right I don't
have the simple property that your value
for the other item is just a linear
fraction value of the first one it's
only on Ray's so the simple solution we
had here is not going to apply the
general paths so we have to address two
things the most important one is the
first one I want to focus on that yeah
okay
so I want you to remember that when
you're optimizing revenue there isn't
the point wise off of my code is not
some mechanism that for every input
gives you the best revenue possible on
that input okay so you have to run ex-
revenant expectation for the dissolution
of types okay so I want to give you the
following definition and I want to
explain it to you and this definition
don't you think analogously to Tim's
definition of smoothness this is a
definition that if I can get it to do
interesting things and then it's an
interesting definition ok so I'm going
to call a function which is a will call
a candidate virtual value function okay
which maps types to real number so it's
going to be a multidimensional virtual
value if it is one the following so it's
an amortization of revenue if virtual
surplus is equal to revenue an
expectation meaning expected virtual
surplus equals expected payment okay for
any I cir mechanism you choose it always
amortizes revenue okay i'm going to call
this function incentive compatible if
the virtual surplus Maximizer meaning
the X where you always choose to give
the player the thing that maximizes is
virtual value function if that X is
incentive compatible meaning what does
mean for XP in Seneca battle there
exists a p such that x PSI see right
okay i'm going to call it a virtual
value if both a and B hold meaning for
all mechanisms this thing will account
for revenue and if I optimize this
function point wise the result i get is
incentive compatible okay and here is
the simple proposition that you can have
if this definition is true okay if a
virtual value exists then the virtual
value surplus Maximizer is optimal okay
and that proof is simple so let X be the
virtual surplus Maximizer we know that
is revenue is equal to its virtual
surplus it maximizes virtual surplus
amongst all mecca's so it's better than
any other X and that X is equal to the
vert of the revenue to the other
mechanism
and the great thing about this is we
took this challenge where there was no
point wise awful mechelen for revenue
and if you can find a virtual surplus
virtual value function then you get a
point wise optimization you can solve ok
so again analogous to smoothness but
really nice thing about smoothest is you
can analyze super appoint argument about
some input and it holds for like
distributions over stuff and all those
other stuff that you don't want to
analyze so it's actually serving a very
similar purpose to that definition
okay so I'm going to skip the single
dimensional linear discussion talk about
m equals two okay so here is in one
slide how you need to think about
multi-dimensional Beckham's I'm to find
virtual value functions so Roche
characterized any incentive pal
mechanism as inducing a utility function
that was convex and you can always
pinpoint the allocation rule of that
mechanism as the gradient of the utility
function okay then in a later paper he
show you how you can view this to come
up with a amortization of revenue okay
you just write revenue a surplus minus
utility surplus minus utility and then
you integrate by parts on pass to write
this utility in terms of gradients of
utility okay and then if you do that
right you can factor out the grading
utility and just get a payment in terms
of allocation again um for two
dimensions there's a degree of freedom
picking paths for one dimension there's
no debris or you have to walk past
downward for two dimension there's a
degree of freedom okay and so that
degree of freedom is going to give you a
lot of possible amortizations and most
of them all except for one are not going
to incentive compatible and only maybe
one all except for maybe one are not
going to incentive compatible so how do
you find the right one and so the main
idea from this paper with with nima
which lets you find multi Mitchell
Berkshire values is an idea for reverse
engineering virtual values in other
words I want to reduce this degree of
freedom I have ok so I'm going to guess
the form of the awful mechanism and use
that guess to reduce the degree of
freedom from choosing paths ok so if
i'll call them mechanism us a favor item
projection as i said before if it always
allocates as if it projects first and
then runs the American ISM first but
favor item projection ok if a favorite
and projection is optimal then it better
be your multi dimensional virtual value
for your favorite
item is equal to the virtual value of a
writer protection so now one of my
virtual values in my two-dimensional
virtual value is known it's a favorite
item virtual value I can use that
virtual value and the differential
equation i get from this integration by
parts to solve for the other one now
I've identified one virtual value
function and all I have to do with
identify sufficient conditions that my
initial guess is correct so I need to
guess that maximizing virtual surplus
indeed gives me this projection okay
which means if this if the virtual value
is positive for the favorite item it
better be bigger than your virtual 84
your other item that virtually every
other item comes out of the differential
equations i get by starting here and
going through the differential equations
from roche and if they're both met if
the if the favor item is negative they
better both be negative so I don't
allocate it all if that's true it's
optimal and then the conditions I gave
on the on the previous and the first
slide are exactly the oceans you need to
check out that this is true okay so to
conclude I've shown you a lot of aspects
in which multi-dimensional and nonlinear
mekkin design Theory can mirror what we
understand and work within the single
dimensional space there's a lot of value
in taking that perspective in part
because a lot of results will
automatically extend and there's a lot
known about that the tools you work
within the in those settings so in
particular I gave you a couple multi
single agent reductions we talked about
marginal revenue which is a very useful
economic intuition about how optimal
auctions work and I showed you how to
derive multi-dimensional virtual values
which is the workhorse of all of single
dimensional auction theory and they're
in lots of extensions using virtual
values and the hope we have for this
theory of virtue advise we develop for
multidimensional settings is one you'll
be able to use virtual values for more
kinds of problems than just showing the
paper item projection is optimal
and to that that these virtual value
that this kind of virtualize Willa Mae
similarly enable a theory for
multi-month preferences like that we've
had four single dimensional preferences
all right thank you